die waren angetreten die grünen um den
kanzler zu stellen eigentlich annalena
baerbock und robert habeck sehen sie
hier hinter uns von einem übergroßen
olaf scholz geschrumpft erst sind sie im
wahlkampf geschrumpft die grünen
trotzdem dann haben sie es mit an die
regierung geschafft und jetzt werden sie
ihm noch mal geschrumpft vom
bundeskanzler himself von olaf scholz
wenn er erklärt gleich mehrere große
grüne themen zur chefsache was steckt da
dahinter jan schäfer ist jetzt bei uns
unser politikchef schönes sie hier wie
sie am montag ja klein sind sie geworden
zumindest in ihrer macht in ihren
kompetenzen in ihren entscheidungen die
sie noch treffen dürfen welche themen
hat sich der kanzler himself jetzt unter
den nagel gerissen also das
bemerkenswerteste ist eigentlich die
kotierung der selbsternannten anti
atomkraft partei
auf eu ebene stolz ein großes wort
mitgesprochen schon in den vergangenen
wochen um was geht es es geht um das
thema kernkraft es geht darum dass die
kernkraft künftig als nachhaltige
energie eingestuft werden soll weil sie
eben keine co2 emissionen verursacht und
kerntakt ist natürlich für jeden grünen
und für annalena baerbock und robert
habe ganz besonders dass edith wort
schlechthin so die grünen sind
entstanden ende der 70er jahre aus der
anti atomkraft bewegung und jetzt
plötzlich muss diese partei an der macht
wenige wochen an der macht erleben die
auf eu-ebene ausgerechnet die kernkraft
eine nachhaltige technologie wird
ausgerechnet in dem jahr in dem in
deutschland die letzten drei meiler vom
netz gehen also das ist wahnsinnig
bitter das ist eine echte düpierung die
wir sehen und wir haben es gerade
dargestellt auch bildlich also olaf
scholz schrumpft dort die beiden
spitzengrünen auf ein echtes zwergen
niveau und hier nimmt er tatsächlich
robert habeck das thema weg der sitzt
sozusagen auf dem energie thema in
seinem neuen super ministerium hat
scholz ihm einfach mal weg genommen das
hat scholz als vizekanzler der ja war
bis anfang dezember mit angela merkel
schon auf europäischer ebene im vorfeld
ausdiskutiert beide haben erkannt angela
merkel wie auch olaf scholz dass sie
gegen einen massiven block auf eu ebene
stehen dort gibt es unter anderem länder
wie frankreich aber auch osteuropäische
länder die auf kernkraft weiter setzen
wollen weil sie das für ihren strommix
brauchen und weil sie auch sagen
kernkraft ist eigentlich bis auf die
endlagerung eine ziemlich saubere und
durchaus auch recht günstige
energiequelle zur stromerzeugung und von
daher brauchen wir diese kernkraft so
und wenn wir das richtig nachverfolgen
bei allem was wir hören dann wussten die
grünen in den koalitionsverhandlungen
auch schon bescheid dass kam es nicht
ganz überraschend aber es zeigt doch wie
machtlos eigentlich robert habeck und
annalena baerbock in dieser frage jetzt
sind wenn wir uns einmal olaf scholz
anschauen dann ist ganz bemerkenswert
gibt eine parallele die wir ziehen
können zum jahr 2010 und zu angela
merkel damals regierte angela merkel mit
der fdp und es dauerte nur wenige monate
dann rasierte sie auch die fdp damals
fdp chef westerwelle mit seinem
kernthema nämlich mit dem kernthema
steuersenkungen ähnlich haben wir es
hier in einem noch viel schnelleren
tempo also turbo olaf muss man sagen der
rasiert innerhalb nur weniger wochen die
grünen bei ihrem eigenen kernthema beim
thema atomkraft es haben wir robert
habeck geschrumpft gesehen aber auch bei
annalena baerbock muss man sich die
frage stellen oder wir stellen die frage
wird sie von der außenministerin zur
draußen ministerin also auch sie bekommt
ganz wichtige themen die sie als
außenministerin auch gerne angehen
angehen würde so ein bisschen
weggeschnappt welche sind es also olaf
scholz hat deutlich gemacht dass er
beispielsweise auch in der ukraine krise
das heft des handelns so handhaben
möchte und in der hand halten möchte wie
es angela merkel auch getan hat heiko
maas kann man sagen war gut für den ein
oder andern besuch den ein oder anderen
flug ins ausland einfach auch in kontakt
so hat am ende wenn es um knallharte
entscheidung ging dann war es natürlich
angela merkel die diese entscheidung als
bundeskanzlerin getroffen hat und genau
so will es olaf scholz auch handhaben
das haben wir jetzt schon gesehen beim
thema kontakt zu putin beim thema
entwicklung in der ukraine da möchte er
ganz klar die federführung übernehmen
und ist es eigentlich bemerkenswert dass
olaf scholz das innerhalb der ersten
drei wochen seiner amtszeit auch schon
so deutlich deutlich konstatiert danke
an den bildband xf jahren schäfer der
uns hier heute bei bild live erklärt hat
wie der turbo kann olaf scholz mal eben
wichtige grünen themen zur chefsache
erklärt hat und damit annalena baerbock
und robert habe geschöpft hat vielen
dank